president biden's cryptocurrency  executive order let's get into it he's  mandated the treasury department to  publish a report about the future of  money and the problems with the  traditional financial system not bad but  the bad part is the executive order  places urgency on exploring and  developing a cbdc this is concerning  because cbdc's are centralized digital  government currencies governments can  program the money taking away your  financial freedom to spend as you wish  if you're not a good citizen for example  you attended that freedom protest now  the government can confiscate your money  and they can program it so you can't  spend it as you like essentially cbdc's  are a more efficient tyrannical  authoritarian enslavement machine i hope  you're buying bitcoin